non mais sombre un homme est triste un
homme et extrêmement malheureux et on ne
prend pas toujours en compte la vie de
ces gens-là et il faut s'arrêter un jour
pour comprendre
leur souffrance vêtue de noir bandana
vert sur la tête l'homme tient dans sa
main un couteau il est 9h45 il vient
d'attaquer à l'arme blanche 4 enfants en
bas âge dans l'air de jeu du paquet au
bord du lac d'Annecy ce sont deux années
pendant lesquelles je n'ai pas été
heureux je n'ai pas profité cela a
affecté ma vie de famille j'ai manqué
beaucoup de choses dans la vie de mes
enfants à l'école puis les policiers
sont arrivés d'abord en moto ils ont
posé les motos ils devaient y avoir
trois policiers ils ont sorti les armes
et puis ils ont demandé de
se calmer et puis de se mettre à terre
et du coup la saillant il s'est pas mis
à terre et du coup lui ont tirer dessus
il serait né en 1991 et de nationalité
syrienne il est entré de manière légale
sur le territoire français en octobre
2022 en provenance de la Suède où il
était résident depuis 10 ans pays qui
lui a permis d'obtenir le statut de
réfugiés le 26 avril 2023
c'est trop dur
un son de déconnexion de ce qu'est le
monde du football
on écouterait Lionel Messi en novembre
dernier il fait une demande d'asile dans
laquelle il déclaraitre un chrétien de
Syrie c'est d'ailleurs au nom de Jésus
qui la perpétré son attaque comme le
montre cette vidéo
[Applaudissements]
vague d'émotion à l'Assemblée
une demi-heure après avoir appris le
drame d'Annecy les députés se
recueillent une minute de silence il y a
aussi de la colère bien sûr qu'il y a ça
de se dire mais comment c'est possible
quand c'est possible un jardin d'enfance
précipitait il y a un enfant de 22 mois
au moment où on parle qui lutte pour la
vie ses actes se multiplient se répètent
donc j'appelle à une réaction
extrêmement forte à une réaction de tous
ceux qui ne veulent pas que notre
civilisation soit détruite être en ce
moment dans l'hémicycle avec une espèce
de bataille de chiffonnier sur une
recevabilité ou non d'amendements nous
paraît en totale décalage par rapport à
l'effroi qui à mon avis submerge notre
pays une attaque au couteau qui met fin
au débat sur les retraites suspension
séance l'immigration massive incontrôlée
tu plutôt que de nous lamenter à chaque
nouveau crime mettons enfin un coup
d'arrêt à l'immigration de masse Olivier
marlès c'est ce que vous êtes allé un
petit peu trop vite en besogne est-ce
que vous regrettez ces propos est-ce que
c'est le temps de l'émotion genre
aucune récupération vous avez évidemment
des gens qui sur notre sol ont des
visées qui peuvent être réviser
criminelles mais vouloir en faire un
fait général ce serait la coupable
qu'est-ce que ce chrétien d'Orient
prétendu chrétien d'Orient parce que je
ne suis pas sûr qu'il soit vraiment
chrétien il s'est déclaré chrétien comme
d'autres se déclarent homosexuels comme
d'autres
à chaque fois pardon mais on a affaire
un peu au même aux mêmes origines
du mal
et qui est aujourd'hui le fait que oui
dans notre pays
par des il y a des catégories que les
gens savent très bien qu'ils sont très
bien conseillés par des associations ici
qui leur disent exactement ce qu'il faut
dire les indices qui sont homosexuels
les autres disent qu'ils sont des femmes
battues les troisièmes disent qu'ils
sont des chrétiens d'Orient et ça ça
rentre dans les cases et ainsi on les
accueille et je pense qu'avant de
s'emballer sur des conclusions sur ces
sujets il faut attendre que l'enquête
puisse avoir lieu je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le temps de
l'émotion ça doit être le temps de
l'unité le président de la République à
lui réagit dans un tweet Emmanuel Macron
a dénoncé une attaque d'une lâcheté
absolue la nation est sous le choc
ajoute-t-il